Hello, everyone.
I'm Dr. Dusha
Cummins, a faculty
member on the
Arkansas campus.
We will be discussing
the pharmacologic
management of ADHD
during this session.
I have included on
your slide set my email
address and the
phone number to my
office. You're welcome
to reach out to me
at any time if you have
questions. I'm glad
to speak with you
in person over the
phone via email or
set up a Zoom session.
so you have already
reviewed the objectives
for this session I
will add that this
topic is a great
review of some other
pharmacologic concepts
which you have discovered
elsewhere and so I
hope this is a good
opportunity for you
to review some things
as well to tie new
concepts together we
do not have a lot
of drug therapies to
discuss it discuss so
I want to make sure
that you are aware
of key differences.
It is very important
with this patient
population, as with
all conditions, that
we have a good
understanding of drug
therapies and their
adverse effects because
it is the mechanism
of action and the
adverse effects which
really distinguish
these medications
from each other when
we look at the
classes used for ADHD.
I've included how
this topic maps to
blueprints for both
USMLE and for Comlex,
this is just for
your information.
So let's get started.
I will start by
emphasizing that
pharmacotherapy for managing
ADHD is only one
treatment modality.
Medications alone may
not be sufficient to
obtain the intended
outcome or reach
desired goals of therapy.
It's easy to think
about drug therapy only
with this condition,
but other components
of therapy include
psychosocial stimulants
such as behavioral
therapy and training
interventions.
These other therapies
are particularly
important,
especially for young
patients such as
four to five-year
-old patients in
whom we may not want
to start drug
therapies just yet.
However, these
additional therapies
can be used in
patients of all ages.
I won't go into great
detail, but I will
describe some of what
these therapies involve.
Behavioral therapy tends
to involve training
of the adults who
interact with the
pediatric ADHD population,
whether there's
caregivers or
teachers. This helps
these individuals
learn skills to help
manage the patients.
Training interventions
are targeted towards
skill development in
the patients themselves
and revolve around
feedback over time.
The third bullet
under psychosocial
treatment includes
mindfulness, cognitive
training, and dietary
modifications.
These other therapies
have not been
systemically evaluated
and analyzed,
but you do see
them mentioned in
the literature,
and I wanted to
include them for
completeness.
Some key considerations
in using drug therapy.
Keep in mind we're
trying to control
symptoms and behavior
in these patients
that impair learning
and development.
Thus, goals are very much
individualized to
specific behaviors,
academic goals,
and social targets.
To meet these goals,
it's important
that we identify
before patients start
drug therapy what
the goals actually
are, because that
is the only way to
really determine if
we're meeting our
goals once drug
therapy is initiated.
One of the take-home
points I hope you
gain from this lecture
is that response to
medications is not a
paradoxical effect.
We use the term
stimulant quite a bit,
and we'll talk about
that a little more.
This can be confusing
because stimulant
sounds very
counterintuitive
when we're talking
about a condition
in which patients
look hyperactive.
We're going to delve
into the pharmacological
understanding of
why the drug classes
we use to treat ADHD
are thought to work.
But it's not a
paradoxical effect.
There's a proposed
mechanism based on our
current understanding
of how these drugs work.
And I highlight this
because you may find
yourselves in a position
to educate others
on this mistruth of
the paradoxical effect.
So in order to understand
these concepts,
we need to discuss
the default
mode network, which
is sometimes referred
to as our default
attention mode.
This is a network
between various parts of
our brain. More
specifically, the connections
are between the
prefrontal cortex, which
controls our decision
-making and executive
functioning, and our
medial parotel lobe and
posterior cingulate,
which help us with
integration of information
and memory recall.
Normally, this
default mode is
active during a
resting state.
For example, if you're
sitting in a chair
thinking about what
you're going to do
for the day or
whenever you're not
actively engaged in
a task, this default
mode is active. One
way to think about it
is as a normal
background active state.
Typically, when
we switch from a
resting state to
attend a task, this
default attention
mode is inhibited.
The background activation
gets turned off normally.
Our understanding is
that there is a lack
of inhibition in the
ADHD population that
causes them not to
suppress this background
activation state when
they need to focus.
Thus, the
consequences look like
inattentiveness and or
lack of impulse control.
So to summarize, one
way to think about
it precisely is that
there's a failure of
an inhibitory system
in these patients.
Their inhibition of
the default attention
mode, for whatever
reason, is not there.
So how do we help this
pharmacologically
speaking?
The proposed benefit
of the medications
is that they work
by increasing
dopamine and or
norepinephrine.
And by increasing these
neurotransmitters,
we help reestablish
the connections that
restore this inhibition
that is lacking.
More specifically,
it's thought that
dopamine helps
restore the overall
inhibitory effect that
is lacking and norepi
strengthens the
signals between the
areas of the brain
within the network.
I know you've seen this
biosynthesis flowchart
before. Keep in mind,
just to help you
with this topic we're
discussing now, that
dopamine and norepi are
structurally similar.
And when you look at
this closely, you see
that they only differ
by a hydroxyl group.
I mention this
because we'll discuss
neurotransmitter
transporters, which, again,
you've also discussed
that elsewhere.
Our images show
neurotransmitter,
excuse me,
transmitter-specific
transporters. However,
the transporters
are really not that
specific and the type
of neurotransmitter
they recognize and
take up, for instance.
And it goes back to
this structure. When we
look at dopamine and
norepinephrine, they're
very, very similar. So
these neurotransporters,
even though we
call some neuro
epitransporters and some
dopamine transporters,
they can also
transport the other
neurotransmitter because,
frankly, they're not that
different when you
look at the structure.
And we can talk about
the treatment of
ADHD without revisiting
this image as well.
Just as a quick
review here, and
I know you know
this really well,
tyrosine is taken up
into the presynaptic
neuron, converted
into dopamine. which
is then taken up
into the storage
vesicle, where it's
converted into norepi.
And then norepi is
released into the synapse
when an action potential
comes along and
this vesicle fuses with
the surface membrane.
Norepi is normally
taken back up into
the presynaptic neuron
via these transporters
that I just
mentioned. And as you
can see, there are
several medications
slash substances
which can impact, i.e.
block the transport of
the neurotransmitter
back up into the
presynaptic neuron.
You often see *******
on these images as
a classic example,
but there are other
things besides *******
that have similar
properties, such
as tricyclic
antidepressants, and as
we'll talk about later,
methylphenidate. So
even though our classic
diagrams like this
include *******,
For our purposes,
we're looking at a
medication such as
mentholfenidate, which
we'll discuss in a
little bit more detail.
So let's look at
this in a different
context, which
will hopefully
help you via a
different route.
This is another
image you've
seen before,
this flowchart.
This will help us
revisit, remind
ourselves about
some adrenergic
agonists and
their subfamilies.
This is from the
classic pharmacology
textbook Goodman
and Gilman's. I've
taken the liberty
of adding on my
version of this,
the term or the word
relative, relative
classification.
And this is because
if you look in
other references,
you may see some
slight differences
as far as mechanisms
of some of these
medications listed.
However, by
convention, we
typically use this
classification.
And so I'm
sticking with it.
So if we look
on the left, we
have the direct
acting category.
And basically, that
means that each
of these individual
agents only act
at specific receptors.
The selective
direct acting
agents agonize just
alpha-1, alpha-2,
beta-1, et cetera.
An example of this
is phenylephrine.
The non-selective
direct acting
directly work on more
than one receptors,
such as alpha
-1 and alpha-2.
So direct acting is
one side. we've got
indirect acting on the
far right, and there
are a few substances that
have mixed properties.
So we will be talking
about today the
indirect acting
medications, specifically
the first two of the
four listed releasing
agents, which include
the amphetamine family,
and then the re-uttake
inhibitor, specifically
methylphenidate,
which isn't listed,
but this is the category
in which it falls.
So let's
conceptualize this
using some yet
more images.
As we discussed
earlier, if we look at A
on this slide, this
is a typical synapse.
And so if we look at
these little red dots
in the synapse, these
represent a typical
amount of the neurotransmitter
norepinephrine
that is normally
released into the
synapse when an action
potential comes along.
If we jump down at C,
this is the illustration
for drugs that block
the reuptake of
neurotransmitters such
as norepinephrine. And
so if you look at the
volume or the amount
of little red dots
in the synapse, it's
more than what we have
in a typical state up
in A. And so this is
a representation of
medications that block
reuptake, and therefore
you have more
neurotransmitters in the
synapse to exert its
effect down the road.
So let's go back up
to B. B is an image,
a representation of
our understanding of
how the amphetamine
family works. So the
amphetamines have
multiple mechanisms, and
they ultimately
cause more release of
neurotransmitter into
the synapse, but they
have a couple different
ways they do it.
One of the things that
is interesting about
the amphetamine family
is that they are called
pseudosubstrates
and so they can both
block the reuptake of
neurotransmitters at the
transporters and they
also themselves can
be taken up into the
presynaptic neuron and
so if you look at this
the little black dots
are the amphetamine
drug and so some of it
gets taken up into
the transporter it can
either block it or it
can be taken out by it
which is interesting
but when the medication
is taken up into the
presynaptic neuron, the
amphetamine then
enters those storage
vesicles and displaces
the little red dots, which
remember is norepinephrine
in this slide.
So there's more norepi
out in the outside
the storage granule.
And then we've
got another process
called reverse
transport, where the
norepinephrine goes
back. There's so
much of it inside
that presynaptic neuron
that it flows out
of the neuron back
into the synapse.
So we'll summarize
this later, but
there's basically three
mechanisms tied to
amphetamines. They
block the reuptake
of norepi at these
transporters. They
themselves are taking
up into the neuron
and then into the
storage vesicle,
displace norepi, and
then norepi goes back
out via reverse
transport. So a little
complex, but multiple
steps. And I wanted
to review that in
detail. So hopefully
you're clear on the
mechanism for amphetamines.
It definitely shares
one property with
the methylphenidate
class, but the amphetamine
family has additional
pharmacology.
So a point of
emphasis, when we talk
about the stimulants
in the treatment of
ADHD, we're talking
about two families
of medications,
basically the amphetamine
family and then
methylphenidate.
When we look over
the decades of drug
development, there's a
really, really long list.
I certainly don't
expect you to memorize
this, but I just want
to demonstrate there
are a lot of different
products that have
been developed over
time. However, when
you look at the actual
ingredients, they're
either they're not
that many medications.
There are a lot of
stimulants, a lot
of amphetamine
derivatives, derivatives
and several methylphenid
derivatives.
but there's not
nearly as many as
what it looks like
on this slide because
a lot of these are
different versions
of the same thing,
if you will.
So let's look at a
case. This is TJ. He's
an eight-year-old boy
who's in the third grade.
He was recently
diagnosed with ADHD after
his teacher noticed
that he does not follow
through on task. He's
easily distracted,
very forgetful, and
does not listen, seem
to listen. Social and
behavioral interventions
have been initiated
at home, and school.
However, the decision
has been made to begin
pharmacotherapy
since he continues to
struggle. What is a
reasonable recommendation?
So, we will start
by discussing the
stimulant class.
We have two overall
classes. We have the
stimulant class, and
then we have the
non-stimulant class.
So, stimulant class
to review first.
As I've already
said, the stimulants
include the amphetamine
family, and then
methylphenidate.
The stimulants are
considered first
-line therapy
because they
work very well.
I posed the question
in your CPG, what
is a stimulant in
the context of ADHD?
And if I had asked
you this a month
ago, you may have
answered that, well,
caffeine's a
stimulant or anything
that keeps you awake
is a stimulant.
And that's a general
lay definition.
However, by convention
and in the pharmacology
world, when we talk
about stimulants
and the management
of ADHD, we're
referring to the
amphetamine family meds and
methylphenidate. So
it's not a term that
is used to reference
a mechanism of action,
which I understand
is a bit confusing.
Stimulant is historically
used to refer
to these two families
of medications in
the treatment of ADHD
because they have
***** potential, which
we'll talk about here
shortly. So don't
let this confuse you.
Recap, the term is not
necessarily tied to
mechanism of action,
but by convention
refers to amphetamines
and methylphenidate.
Again, these are
considered first line
therapy. The
exceptions would be if
you have a patient
with certain
comorbidities, which
we'll also discuss.
us. Approximately, when
we look at response
rates to the stimulant
class, we see
approximately 40% of
patients respond to both
the amphetamines
and methylphenidate.
However, another 40%
only respond to one or
the other. So what
this means clinically
is that there may be a
trial and error period
to find the best
medication for a patient.
And there's some very
rational examples
why there are
differences. It could be
pharmacogenetic
differences, for instance.
Thus, it's worth
exploring different
options in patients.
Even if you
stay within the same
family of treatment
options, patients
may respond to
one medication and
yet not another.
And last point here,
ADHD subtypes do
not necessarily
predict response
to specific agents,
such as inateninous
itself doesn't
necessarily, you
don't see a better
response with one
versus the other.
So general
considerations with
stimulants, again,
this includes
amphetamines and
methylphenidate.
There are several
formulations
of both of
these available.
Again, you're not
expected to memorize all
this, but you are
expected to know some
general pros and cons
of when you might
use one over the other,
such as immediate
release products
versus delayed release.
Immediate release
products have
a benefit of
dosing in smaller
doses for
younger children.
A downside, however,
since they're immediate
release is that
they are short-acting,
so you may have to
give a second dose
during the school day.
Delayed release
formulations have the
benefit of less frequent
dosing. However,
they may last longer
than needed, and some
patients may have
their sleep impacted.
Excuse me.
there are some products
that have a blend
of immediate release
plus delayed release
there's a transdermal
delivery system there's
a suspension so obviously
we've got several
options and I don't
expect you to memorize
all these but to
understand you know some
of the situations
where you might prefer
one over the other so
let's start with a more
specific conversation
about amphetamines.
I use MOA for mechanism
of action. It's a
little interesting
or confusing because
amphetamines refers to a
drug class, and there's
also a specific drug
amphetamine. So just
keep that in mind. As
I've already referenced,
the amphetamines work
by several mechanisms,
but they ultimately
cause more dopamine
and norepi to be
available in the synapse
By those three mechanisms
I mentioned earlier,
displacement from
presynaptic vesicles,
reverse transport
of norepi, and then
a lesser effect, but
it's still there,
the blockade of
the reuptake of
dopamine and norepi
via the transporters.
Note that there are
different isomers
of amphetamine, and
it's believed that
the D isomer is the
one that is more
potent in the CNS,
which is where we
want it to work. that
L-isomer is associated
with more
cardiovascular actions.
I highlight this because
this partly explains
one reason why we have
so many formulations
of amphetamine.
There's a pure
dextroamphetamine
formulation that's available.
There are some
formulations that have
a blend of the DNL,
and then there's one
that's actually a
resigment mixture.
So clinically, is
there much difference?
It's really hard to
prove that, but there are
options available.
If a patient doesn't
tolerate one, et cetera,
respond to one version,
then there are options
to try another.
There's also a formulation
of dexamphetamine
that has lysine
attached to it. And
I have seen this as
a question before on
board exam prep. So
it's worth noting the
rationale behind
this is that the
conversion to dexamphetamine
is slowed down
because the lysine
must be removed. So
theoretically, this may
reduce the potential
for ***** because of
a delaying effect.
However, there's
little data to show
that there's an
increased risk of *****,
but that is the
rationale why
this product is
on the market.
And lastly, just as
an interesting fact,
methamphetamine
became approved or
was approved for
ADHD back in 1943.
It is still available
in generic form
as a prescription
drug for this
condition. However,
it's rarely used.
So our second
type of stimulant
is, of course,
methylphenidate.
Again, the mechanism
of action is
inhibition of the
neurotransmitters,
therefore causing
increased amount of both
dopamine and norepi
in the synapse.
It's considered a non
-selective reuptake
inhibitor because
it blocks reuptake
of more than one
neurotransmitter.
I have included
trade names on here,
as I have elsewhere
in the slide.
I don't expect you
to memorize that.
This is just to help
you with familiarity
because some
of these names,
generic names, can
get a little complex.
As with the
amphetamine family,
multiple formulations
of methylphenidate
are available,
including a D
-isomer, which is
also the active form.
The following two
slides, just to reiterate
what we've already
talked about, and so
I won't go back into
this in more detail.
It's just a different
way of looking
at what we talked
about previously.
Excuse me, this
slide, you'll know
there are norepi
transporters, the NET,
this slide, dopamine.
Just to reiterate the
fact that ultimately
these transporters
are not that selective
between the two. And
with the stimulant
family, again, we
believe that it's the
increased availability
of both dopamine and
norepi in these patients
which help them.
so overall initiation
titration and
monitoring of of all
the stimulants drug
therapy should be
chosen obviously on an
individualized basis
and when you consider
things like dosing
timing adverse effects
which formulation
is best tolerable
cost you know all that
has to be considered
there are several
monitoring parameters
that need to be
established or conducted
at baseline and
throughout therapy.
This slide includes
general recommendations
for both titration
and monitoring.
There is some
variability in these
recommendations
amongst groups. I
have tried to follow
what the American
Academy of Pediatrics
recommends.
A key takeaway point
is that it's necessary
to monitor these
patients and have close
follow-up, especially
after a patient is, after,
excuse me, a medication
is initiated. The
stimulant medications
can be titrated fairly
quickly if it's tolerated
because typically
you see a response or
not fairly soon. It
is recommended that
you have a face-to-face
follow-up for these
patients because they
tend to be young, and
you definitely want to
catch if they're having
any adverse effect.
Adverse effects with
the stimulant family
are typically dose
-related, which makes
sense when we look
at the pharmacology.
Dosing stimulants
early in the day using
immediate release
product formulations
can be helpful because,
as you would expect,
these medications
are associated with
insomnia with delayed
release formulations
and so if if you
get to if you have a
choice between immediate
delayed you know
think about impact
on sleep you know the
immediate products acting
products don't last
as long so they're
less likely to impact
sleep the delayed
release products last
longer and so depending
on what time of
the day their dose
they could impact sleep
growth suppression
has been associated
specifically with
methylphenidate but we still
monitor growth in
patients who are on
amphetamines the growth
suppression is minimal
for most children
children will lose may
lose some weight and
it may have some impact
on height is typically
not a huge impact
studies indicate that
in the first year of
methylphenidate use
most patients will lose
an average of about
three kilos the weight
loss will taper over
time and again most
of the impact isn't
in the first year but
we do want to keep a
close eye on that it's
important for you
to note that the the
impact on weight is due
to reduced food intake
and the patients just
aren't as hungry as
before they were on
the medication so it's
not due to an alteration
in metabolism it's
due to reduced food
intake again and this
is helpful to know
because you can work
with the patient and
the caregivers to ensure
that when these
patients do eat, we
actually want them to
eat something that's high
calorie, a high calorie
meal or high calorie
stack so we can
maintain their growth.
Lastly, we do have
headaches and abdominal
pain. Sometimes there's
adverse effects.
We see that with this
patient population.
Those both tend to
subside over time.
So the next set of
adverse effects includes
our cardiovascular
effects. It's not
surprising because we're
impacting repinephrine
that we can see
slight increases in
heart rate and slight
increases in blood
pressure. And some
patients were talking about
one to two beats per
minute for heart rate
and one to four
millimeters of mercury
for systolic and diastolic
for blood pressure.
Some patients may
have more pronounced
effects than that, 5
to 15%. So it's not
a majority, but it is
while we monitor this
heart rate and blood
pressure in all
patients at baseline
and throughout therapy.
So additional
baseline screening
recommendations
should also include a
family history of
cardiovascular disease,
including the ones
I've listed on
the slide. I won't
read all of them.
And the patients
themselves, if
they have a known
history of any type
of structural
cardiac disease,
then stimulants
should be avoided.
It's not
recommended that all
patients get a
baseline EKG, all
patients put on
stimulants, that is.
However, if a patient
themselves has
a risk factor, it
is recommended that
those patients do
get a baseline EKG.
But again, it's not
recommended that all
patients on stimulant
therapy get an ECOG.
I've included this
slide for completeness
sake, and I won't
delve into the
details, but this
is a fairly recent
study, a review
rather, looking at
stimulants and the
correlation between
medications and
cardiovascular events.
And I included this
again just as an FYI.
It included about 19
different studies. And
overall, basically, it
shows what the current
literature supports.
And that is that it
does not appear to be
overt cardiovascular
risk when we look
at the well-screened
patient population and
cardiovascular impact.
So finishing up
with our stimulant
class, one of the
things we need to
include here that
ticks are potential
adverse effects
with stimulants.
A tick is a
brief, repetitive,
recurrent motor
contraction, and it
can be precipitated
by a stimulant.
However, if a
patient has responded
well to their stimulant
and the tick is
not interfering with
their educational
or day-to-day activities,
it is acceptable
to leave them on
the medication.
But if the reverse
is true, if the
tick is bothersome
to their education
and day-to-day life,
then it may be best
to take them off of
stimulant therapy
and try one of the
non-stimulants.
Priapism, which is
a prolonged ********
for more than four
hours, has been
associated with
stimulant use, primarily
methylphenidate.
And so it's not very
common, but it is
included in one of the
potential adverse
effects to be aware of.
so it's a fair question
do stimulants help
improve scholastic
performance because that
is one of our goals in
many of our patients
data currently indicates
that performance
improves in elementary
students reading and
math scores compared
to non-treated patients
however scores
still lie behind non
-ADHD peers but
for the individual
patient they there
is some benefit.
There are standard
scales used at baseline
at diagnosis to
evaluate future therapy.
You may be familiar
with the Connor scale.
The scales help us with
some consistency in
assessment from when
the patient is diagnosed
and then treated and
helped us to objectively
determine medications
help patients. So
I wanted to be aware
there is an objective,
a parameter to use when
we're looking at the
benefit or lack thereof
in these patients.
so what do we do if a
patient doesn't respond
to their initial
stimulant medication
well you can increase
the dose which is
pretty straightforward
i do want to say be wary
of really high off-label
doses of stimulants
because there are
that is sometimes
an approach keep in
mind as we said that
adverse effects are
dose related and so
increasing the dose beyond
what is published in
the recommendations
is just can be risky.
There also may be
some rational reasons
why patients don't
respond to certain
medications, you know,
such as pharmacogenetic,
excuse me, pharmacokinetic
differences
within that individual
patient. They may
have a pharmacogenetic
profile where they
don't metabolize the
medications as well.
They may have a
difference in their um
their transporters for
these neurotransmitters
so um there can
be some some real
variability which is
why there's a bit of
a trial and error in
some patients to find
find the best therapy
currently we do
not do pharmacogenetic
testing in all
patients because it's
not a high yield thing
and then um a last
point on this when
when someone tells
you the medication
didn't work It's real
important you get
a specific history
because it could
be that it worked
initially and then
we're off throughout
the day. You know,
maybe they need a
long acting product.
And so you need to
be specific when
someone says or
find out specifics,
because it may be a
little more complicated
than whether it's just
didn't work at all.
So to finish
our statement
discussion, there is
a warning regarding
*****, misuse
and addiction.
I pulled the
specific warning from
Adderall, and there's
a warning because
there may be an
increased risk for *****
of potential with
these medications.
However, data
currently do not
indicate that
a patient is at
increased risk
for abusing drugs.
Because of their
pharmacology, this
black box warning
has been added.
So it's definitely
something to be aware of.
But right now we
don't have evidence
that patients
who are placed on
stimulants for this
condition have an
increased risk of
abusing medications.
Now, if you have a
patient who has not
started stimulant
therapy yet and they
already have a history
of substance *****,
then you may want to
consider a different
option in that
patient population.
So we will move on
to the non-stimulant
medications. Just
as a recap, we just
talked about the
stimulants, which include
amphetamines and
methylphenidate. And
now we're moving on
to the handful of
classes that include
the non-stimulant
medication. These are
alternatives to the
stimulants if
comorbidities are present,
which preclude the
use of stimulants.
These do not, they're
not as effective as
the stimulants. That
doesn't mean they don't
work at all. It's just
that they don't tend
to be as effective.
uh it's also worth
noting that they they
have a slower onset of
benefit it may take
two to four weeks um
versus you know a couple
days um with stimulants
there are some shared
concerns when we
look at um adverse
effects to watch out for
and that goes back to
the pharmacology um
patients with
cardiovascular risk factors
um at baseline need to
be further evaluated
with non-stimulants
just as they were as we
said with stimulants
and it's very similar
in EKG consult with
the consult the
cardiologist but again
that's just patients with
risk factors that's
not all patients the
first non-stimulant
we'll talk about is
atamoxetine which is also
known as dratera it is
a selective reutake
inhibitor of norepi so
it does not have an
appreciable effect on
dopamine again it has
a slower therapeutic
benefit or onset of
onset of benefit i have
on here that because
of that you may need
to overlap a stimulant
with a non-stimulant
for transitioning
someone however you would
want to be very
cautious about that and
you would probably want
to seek consultation
of someone that has
done that on a routine
basis because these
drugs all impact NREPI,
if you have a patient
taking two at one
time, even if you reduce
the dose of one, they
could really be
predisposed to adverse
effects. So even though
that is a recommendation,
it's something to
consider seriously.
Adverse effects
with atomoxetine,
there are some
shared similarities
with stimulants,
and then there's
some things that
are different.
The abdominal pain is a
shared adverse effect,
but if you'll see
somnolence is unique.
The stimulants are
associated with insomnia.
Atamoxetine is associated
with making
people sleepy.
You also see decreased
appetite with atamoxetine
as you do with
stimulants, and we've
already mentioned you can
also see some increase
in heart rate and
blood pressure, again,
because it causes
norepi to be increased.
It is metabolized
by one of our P450
systems, and so there
are individuals who
are genetically
predisposed to being
slow metabolizers.
We don't screen for
that, but it is
something to be aware of.
There are rare
cases, case reports
of liver injury
in the literature.
Because it's rare, we
don't routinely screen
these patients for
liver based on liver
disease or throughout
their drug therapy.
These are typically
younger patients that
tend to have healthy
livers to begin with.
However, if the patient
starts to manifest
signs of liver dysfunction,
such as paritis,
dark urine, et
cetera, then you would
stop the medication
and then evaluate them.
And then lastly, we see
that this medication
has a warning about
increased risk
for suicidal ideation,
which seems a bit
random. And this is
because the mechanism,
the reuptake,
blockade and reuptake
of norepi is, we have
some antidepressants
that have that
similar pharmacology.
And currently, all
the antidepressants we
have in the U.S. on
the market carry a
warning about the
potential for increased
suicidal ideation. And
because the pharmacology
is so similar with
atomoxetine, it basically
is required to have
the same warning.
Our next non
-stimulant is the
newest one that
was around or
approved, excuse
me, in 2021. One,
it's very similar
to atomoxetine, even
the generic name
looks similar. Another
selective inhibitor
of norepia reuptake.
Very parallel side
effects, somnolence,
headache,
appetites reduced,
cardiovascular effects
can be there, and
then it's required to
have the same warning
because, again,
its pharmacology is
similar to antidepressants.
So still fairly
new, so we don't
know if there's a lot
to distinguish it
yet from atomoxetine.
So the next class
of non-stimulants
are the alpha-2
adrenergic agonists.
When we look at
their mechanism,
traditionally, when
you talk about this
class, and you will
discuss them more
when you learn
about hypertension,
we attribute
their benefit to
their presynaptic
pharmacology.
They are alpha-2
agonists. And so
one of the things
they do is that
they agonize the
autoreceptor.
And I'm going to jump
ahead here. you have
these autoreceptors
where when there's
enough norepi in the
synapse, it sort of
feeds back to this
autoreceptor and tells
the presynaptor
neuron, no more norepi.
And so that helps
with hypertension
because you have less
neurotransmitter.
However, that doesn't
fit with what we
talked about up to
this point, because all
the other agents we've
talked about have
increased norepi. So
while it didn't make
sense that a drug
that reduces norepi
helps ADHD? Well, it
doesn't. So it's thought
that the benefit in
ADHD is not related
to the presynaptic
autoreceptor. It's
thought that the
postsynaptic alpha-2
receptors are where the
benefit is generated.
So the postsynaptic
effect has been
associated with
increased blood flow and
prefrontal cortexes.
And it's thought that
it's that mechanism
that actually helps with
memory and executive
functioning. So at
least that's our
current understanding.
The alpha-2 agonists
can be used either by
themselves or in
combination with other
ADHD medications. And
like atomoxetine and
filoxazine, they can
be used as options in
patients in whom
stimulants should be
avoided for a certain
concern or comorbidity.
So, the alpha-2
agonists, their
family of adverse
effects, they cause
sedation, which
could be a benefit.
They actually
cause the opposite
effects of the other
drugs when we look
at cardiovascular
effects. They
cause reduced heart
rate, potentially,
and potentially
low blood pressure.
Because of their
mechanism at the
presynaptic alpha
-2 receptor, there's
a potential for
rebound hypertension
if they're
abruptly stopped.
So patients
need to be real
consistent about
taking them.
And then lastly,
constipation
can be an adverse effect.
So now we're going to
talk about a concern
potentially with all
the agents we've talked
about up to this point.
All the stimulants,
the amphetamines
and methylphenidate,
atamoxetine, and
alpha-2. I did not
include viloxazine
because it's still
new and we don't
know if this
applies yet. So I
did exclude that one.
All of these other
agents currently
have a warning about
the potential for
certain psychiatric
adverse effects.
They've mostly
been reported with
stimulants, but
these other agents
have had a few
cases as well.
And this falls
under three specific
categories, psychosis,
mood disturbances,
and then severe
anxiety attacks.
And so this is good
to keep in mind.
It's not something we
see in the majority
of patients, but it's
helpful to know, for
instance, if you have
a patient that have
any of these at
baseline, you need to at
least be aware that
any of these therapies
may exacerbate the
underlying condition.
So I did want to
include a little bit
about a drug holiday
period. There's
not universal
agreement on this. A
holiday is a break
from drug therapy.
It's mostly been
recommended when it is
recommended, which
isn't by everybody,
for stimulants.
It could be over a
weekend. It could
be for a longer
period of time, such
as in the summer.
And not everybody
is of the opinion
these patients should
have a holiday. And
so it's not universally
agreed upon,
but I want you to
be aware of it. So
the potential benefit
is that for patients
who have had an
impact on their
growth, this may allow
them to catch up.
But it's also
a time when you
could re-evaluate
the need for
the patient to
stay on therapy.
But regardless, the
benefit of stopping
versus continuing
the medication
should be evaluated.
So I mentioned this
is primarily
something that might
be considered with
stimulant therapy.
Remember, the non
-stimulants take a while
to work, that delayed
effect to benefit.
So it doesn't really
make sense that we
would have a holiday
with the non-stimulants
because it just
means you'd have to
restart, reinitiate a
drug titation process.
So last medication
I will include, and
I'll put it at the
very end because it's
used in primarily
the adult population,
and you'll see it in
the literature. So
I wanted you to be
aware of that. This
is bupropion. It is
a weak norepi and
dopamine reuptake
inhibitor approved
officially for depression
and smoking cessation,
but it is used off
-label for ADHD.
So you may use
it in patients
or see it used
in patients.
Not surprisingly,
it's adverse effects
along with what
we've seen with
the other medications
that impact
norepine dopamine,
appetite suppression,
insomnia, tachycardia.
It does have
the unique concern
of potentially
lower seizure
threshold. And because
it is an
antidepressant, it also
carries that suicidal
ideation warning.
A practice point I
wanted to include,
I know you haven't
learned a lot yet
about the Drug
Enforcement Agency's drug
schedules. The
stimulants are all
Schedule II drugs, and
that impacts practice
because it impacts
prescriptions.
Specifically,
Schedule II's cannot be
automatically refilled.
Wherever you practice,
you know, make sure
you know what the the
laws are there are
federal laws that
that oversee this but
there could be additional
criteria to consider
at the state
level and then lastly
I'll add it in here
which doesn't really
tie to the DEA thing
but it's something to
consider it is a valuable
consideration in
these patients you
know when to stop therapy
altogether you know
do they need lifelong
therapy do they only
need it during certain
certain phase of
their life you know But
that's an individualized
discussion to have
with patients and
their caregivers and
something to consider.
So in summary,
pharmacotherapy is
only one modality.
Therapeutic
goals should be
identified at the outset.
Stimulants are first
line, but we do a
non-stimulant options
for patients and
home stimulants are
not the best choice.
and in these are patients
you definitely have
to follow you can't
just start a medication
and see them a year
later so periodically
assess them both for
benefit of treatment
and for any adverse
effects that the patient
may be experiencing these
are my core references
so I'll end where
we started what is a
stimulant in the management
of ADHD a stimulant
refers to an amphetamine
type medication
or methamphetamine,
I'm sorry, excuse me,
amphetamine or
methylphenidate.
And then here is
the lecture feedback
form. I will add
that I have my
version of a transcript
for this video
recording uploaded
onto Canvas. And so
you can download
that and you've got
a cleaned up version,
if you will, of
the transcript that
I've edited. And
so that is available
to you. So with
that, good luck.
And please reach out
if you have any
questions. Thank you.